llvm a toolkit used to build and
optimize compilers building a
programming language from scratch is
hard you have humans who want to write
code in a nice simple syntax than
machines that need to run it on all
sorts of architectures llvm standardizes
the extremely complex process of turning
source code into machine code it was
created in 2003 by grad student chris
lattner at the university of illinois
and today it's the magic behind clang
for c and c plus as well as languages
like rust swift julia and many others
most importantly it represents high
level source code in a language agnostic
code called intermediate representation
or ir this means vastly different
languages like cuda and ruby produce the
same ir allowing them to share tools for
analysis and optimization before they're
converted to machine code for a specific
chip architecture a compiler can be
broken down into three parts the front
end parses the source code text and
converts it into ir the middle end
analyzes and optimizes this generated
code and finally the backend converts
the ir into native machine code to build
your own programming language from
scratch right now install llvm then
create a c
file now envision the programming
language syntax of your dreams to make
that high level code work you'll first
need to write a lexer to scan the raw
source code and break it into a
collection of tokens like literals
identifiers keywords operators and so on
next we'll need to define an abstract
syntax tree to represent the actual
structure of the code and how different
tokens relate to each other which is
accomplished by giving each node its own
class third we need a parser to loop
over each token and build out the
abstract syntax tree if you made it this
far congratulations because the hard
part is over now we can import a bunch
of llvm primitives to generate the
intermediate representation each type in
the abstract syntax tree is given a
method called cogen which always returns
an llbm value object used to represent a
single assignment register which is a
variable for the compiler that can only
be assigned once what's interesting
about these ir primitives is that unlike
assembly they're independent of any
particular machine architecture and that
dramatically simplifies things for
language developers who no longer need
to match the output to a processor's
instruction set now that the front end
can generate ir the op tool is used to
analyze and optimize the generated code
it makes multiple passes over the ir and
does things like dead code elimination
and scalar replacement of aggregates and
finally that brings us to the back end
where we write a module that takes ir as
an input that emits object code that can
run on any architecture congratulations
you just built your own custom
programming language and compiler in 100
seconds hit the like button and
subscribe if you want to see more short
videos like this thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one